hello this is brad gaddis the author of
advanced google adwords along with
simplylearn we're going to walk you
through the fundamentals of adwords in
this lesson we will introduce you to how
adwords accounts are structured
so after completing this lesson
you should be able to identify the
differences between a my client center
an account a campaign and an ad group
determine what campaigns an advertiser
should create
know what campaign level settings exist
structure ad groups appropriately
understand where budgets are set
and know the differences between the
main campaign types
so first let's look at an overview of
how accounts are structured
so the top level you have an account an
account is for an advertiser
now an account can be comprised of one
or more campaigns your major targeting
options are set at the campaign level
and we'll look at each of these settings
more in depth in a moment
now a campaign can contain one or more
ad groups
an ad group is a close related set of
keywords and ads
so the account level the options you're
setting
are who has access to the account
everybody can have access
it just requires you to have a google
account which can be connected to your
email
and then emails are added to an account
and multiple people can have access
your billing information is at the
account level
notification access how often you get
notifications and what those
notifications are
your time zone
once a time zone is set for an account
it can't be changed again so it's useful
to set your time zone
in your account to where your main
website's located or where your
corporate office is located
now linked accounts are also set at the
account level linked accounts are things
like google analytics or google
webmaster tools
now at the campaign level this is where
you're going to set most of your
targeting options
so a campaign is comprised of ad groups
all the ad groups and that
campaign will be displayed based upon
your campaign targeting options
so at the campaign level you can set
your network targeting
this is search could be search partners
or search with display select
you set the location where you want your
ads displayed
you choose the language
the add rotation how google serves
multiple ads within an aggregate you
have multiples
your ad serving frequency how quickly or
slowly ads are delivered and your budget
your budgets are by campaign
so if you have multiple goals in your
account
then you can have a different campaign
for each goal
and then set your budgets differently by
campaign
now at the ad group level you'll set
mobile bid modifiers which we'll talk a
lot more in depth when we get into
bidding later on for display you can set
mobile bid modifiers or your display
targeting again we'll get into much more
detail and display targeting in our
display modules
so at ad group level ad serving the
campaign settings dictate how that ad
groups are going to be displayed an ad
group can have multiple keywords or ads
in it now an ad group needs to have at
least one ad to be displayed and at
least one keyword to be displayed
but only ads from an ad group where the
keywords triggered by the search query
are actually shown
so if you have one ad group with a
thousand keywords in it and one ad
your ad is really going to be related to
the search query
so a lot of the structure and adwords
comes from creating
ad groups where the keywords and ads are
related to each other and then creating
multiple ad groups each with related ads
and keywords
now optionally you don't have to use
this but if you're an agency and you
have multiple clients it's a good idea
to use an mcc
which is known as a my client center
a my client center is a way to link
multiple accounts together so you can
log into just an mcc and easily navigate
between your multiple accounts so next
let's talk about the campaign type uses
there's multiple campaign types
so the first campaign type is search
search based campaigns are only shown on
the search network
you can make a display campaign
these are shown on the display network
so search is when someone typed in a
search query and saw results
where display is publisher sites which
are non-search sites and that's been
triggered in various ways across the
display network there's a third option
which is search with display select
so these campaigns are primarily shown
on search but they do allow some
impressions and clicks to come from the
display network so look at the search
campaign your ads are only shown when
someone's actively looking for your
products
so you control exactly what search
queries will trigger your ads based upon
the keywords you choose
so this is a great campaign type for
direct response advertising when you
want your ad to show if someone searched
for you
then you want to use a search campaign
now with display campaigns
it's nice to bring additional exposure
to your business through display
channels there's a lot of targeting
options for display so we'll cover the
in-depth targeting options in a
different module but this is great for
branding purposes now search with
display select
your ads are primarily shown to people
who are searching for you
but you can get some additional exposure
across a display network you don't have
a lot of control over display network
like you would with a display only
campaign
so if you want
to really control how your address shown
on display and use advanced display
options you need a display only campaign
if you want to primarily show your
add-on search but you want some
additional branding and some impressions
across display
then search with display select is a
good campaign type
so this is good for starting with
display if you just want a little bit
display see how it does or you want to
use one budget across both search and
display
this is a good campaign type to use now
let's look at how you should organize
campaigns themselves so campaigns should
be organized by business goals
by budgets
or by grouping similar products and
services together
so if you're an accounting company
and you do taxation you do payroll and
you do auditing these are three very
different themes
so it's useful to make three campaigns
one for each theme that way you can set
a budget for each of the different
services that your company offers and
then make sure the ad groups within each
campaign are related to those particular
themes and campaign overall options and
goals so campaigns are usually segmented
by network if you want the most control
over your ad serving
so for instance you could have a search
campaign about taxation and then a
display campaign about taxation that
would let you control
how your ads are served on search and
how your ads are shown across the
display network individually for that
same theme
now search with display select is an
option if you want a little bit of
display reach but if you really want to
focus on search get a little bit of
display then you can use search with
display select and only have one theme
one campaign per theme across your
account
so for the most control you want a
search and a display campaign for each
theme
for mostly searched advertisers who want
a little bit of display then you can
make search with display select
campaigns and have lots of control over
search and get a little display thrown
in
so campaigns can be organized around
geographies
so if you're a location based business
you've got a lot of locations a lot of
places you offer services you can make
one campaign for each location
so it's a different way to sort of
organize things for location based
companies
now within campaigns campaigns are our
budgets and our global settings of how
our ads are displayed and where they're
displayed a lot of your fundamentals are
going to take be taken care of about the
ad group organization so ad groups
should be organized around close to
related themes so your campaign is a
theme and your ad groups are all the sub
themes that go into that particular
campaign because you want to make sure
that in an ad group
the keywords
the landing page where user goes and the
ads are all related to each other
you don't want an ad group that's
specifically about taxation to go to a
general accounting page you want it to
go to a page that talks about taxation
then you could have a different campaign
and i grew up that's about payroll one
ad group could be corporate payroll one
ad group could be
small business payroll one one ad group
could be corporate payroll services or
payroll software
now those are different types of ideas
so you'd want an ad group within a
campaign about payroll for each of those
ideas so for example what you don't want
to do is have an ad group of keywords
like payroll services small business
payroll online payroll services
corporate payroll services payroll
software in one ad group
and then hope that your ads which one's
up payroll services one's about
corporate payroll services one's about
payroll tax services
in the same ad group because google's
not going to look and say oh that that
keyword is corporate payroll let's show
the corporate payroll ad
any ad from an ad group can show for any
keyword in the ad group so if a user
search for corporate payroll services
right you'd want them to see the ad that
mentions corporate payroll services
the user search for payroll tax services
you'd want an ad that mentions
specifically payroll tax services
now software is different
so someone search for payroll software
you'd want yet a different ad group for
that
so these should be different ad groups
one ad group should be corporate payroll
with a corporate payroll ad a different
ad group should be payroll tax services
a different ad group should be payroll
software
that way your keywords and your ads are
really closely related to each other and
then you can pick a landing page on your
website
that talks specifically about that
keyword and ad so each ad group should
be its own theme
ad groups should be organized around
closely related themes so the ads
keywords and landing pages are highly
related
so the campaign level is more about
here's the different service types we
offer the locations we want to serve
these ads the ad group level is closely
close to related themes of ads keywords
and landing pages so let's recap what we
just learned
so at the top level a my client center
lets you link multiple accounts together
an adwords account is for a business and
that's a collection of campaigns and ad
groups at the account level you set your
email access preferences notification
preferences
billing and linked other accounts
campaigns
are where
you choose your network settings you
choose your location settings your big
ad serving settings are set at the
campaign level so campaigns should be
organized
around themes or business objectives
ad groups are a collection of ads and
keywords ad groups are shown based upon
the campaign level settings that
dictates your overall setting
but only ads can show for an ad group
that is triggered by the keywords in
that same ad group so ad groups should
be highly highly related themes of very
close related keywords and ads and then
a landing page
so the user who does a search query
triggers your keyword which makes your
ad show the ad should be related to the
search query what a user typed into the
engine
then if they click on your ad because
your ad was compelling they go to your
landing page that landing page should be
related to the search query if you look
at a search query
and you see that you have a better
ad group or landing page or ad for that
query than the one currently showing you
should make another ad group so that the
queries keywords ads and landing pages
are all highly interrelated to each
other
because that makes sure that users doing
a search
see ads related to what they do see a
landing page related to what they're
looking for
and that's going to increase the number
of people who actually do business with
your company
so this concludes our information about
adwords account structure
now in our next lesson
we'll look at keywords and really dig
into them and match types which dictate
how closely related a query has to be to
your keyword before an ad can be
displayed
you